thank you
it is a very deep dive with not
repercussions to that come up too fast
bubbles will form inside your blood
inside your tissues and cause ill
effects
to get to 90 meters you'd be looking at
four or five minutes to get down there
it's very dark because you're very deep
so there's very little light penetration
come down in the dark
and you start to slowly realize there's
some shape coming up ahead underneath
you
the atmosphere at the wreck when you
arrive there is quite spooky
the very first thing I noticed
there was a lot of net
it's basically rope knitting so very
heavy but it does cover everything
the problem was that we were not a
hundred percent sure that the that the
ship is scarves
so we decided to go and try and find the
name written on the ship
which in a more luxurious ship would be
bronze or brass letters riveted into the
hull
as we neared the bow the the amount of
netting seemed to increase and what you
don't want to do as a diver is try to
get under it because that risks you
being trapped
Tangled within it
to be able to uncover the letters we had
to cut some of the Nets away
[Music]
it wasn't easy but eventually once the
Nets dropped away we could finally see
what lay beneath
what became apparent was that the the
bridge area was heavily damaged
there's a huge hole in the middle of the
ship
[Music]
foreign